already working our way through a busy
week yes the calendar says June but
mandatory minicamp nine of them this
week there will be more coming up next
week the off season programs getting
intense competition no contact no
contact but it's still some some fierce
competition that these offseason
workouts and specifically at mandatory
minicamp we talked last hour about guys
like Tom Brady showing up lady on bail
showing up a couple of guys in Detroit
not showing up Darius slay and Damon
snacks Harrison will skip the mandatory
minicamp at the price of 88 thousand six
hundred and fifty you know this this is
the the centerpiece and we're like Chris
for years this is all they did in the
offseason they would do a mint a mini
camp and that's it and now it's this
nine week ordeal aimed at keeping the
guys in shape even though most of them
already staying in shape yes they are
but at the same time I think this is why
we see so many injuries through OTAs too
because guys aren't good in enough shape
yet to be going out in the field and
doing pass rush drills or one-on-one
drills I mean hey three out of the top
seven picks and our last NFL Draft are
hurt and can't even practice already
because they had injuries right off the
bat so I do think there's a little bit
too much of a rush always to get out
there and these OTAs and do that this
day and age where like you said back in
back you know 80's 90's it was just the
mini camp and you got the rest of the
offseason to train but it's still a very
important part of the year glad to see
brady Le'Veon Bell there certainly you
know especially loving a belt he'll back
some of the people in New York off of
him a little bit and back in the 60s and
70s the players had other jobs in the
offseason they didn't stay in shape the
the cleats got thrown into the closet
and then when it was time to go to
training camp they had to work and work
there to put down the cigarettes they
had to work there to put down the
brisket they had to work to get
themselves into shape and they had six
preseason games back when there were 14
regular season games Chris there were
six preseason games in 1978 they moved
that point from 6 and 14 to 4 and 16 and
it's been nearly a decade now that the
Commissioner periodically questioning
the value of four preseason games he was
add it again on Monday at the Jim Kelly
annual golf tournament in Buffalo here's
what the Commissioner had to say about
the current slate of four preseason
games talking about coaches that four
preseason games is necessary anymore to
get ready for a season to evaluate
players develop players there are other
ways of doing that and we've had a lot
of discussions about that and you know I
feel like what we should be doing is
always to the highest quality and I'm
not sure preseason games to meet that
he's been saying that for ten years
although he hasn't said it much recently
here's the thing Chris the NFL wants to
move that point again it went from six
and 14 to 4 and 16 they want to move it
to 2 and 18 they're not going to reduce
the preseason without increasing the
regular season and it is not a
coincidence that Roger Goodell is making
these comments publicly less than a week
after reports emerged that the NFL wants
to get 18 regular season games as a
result of the ongoing labor negotiations
with the NFL PA this is the push and
whenever Roger Goodell assaults the
preseason the message is we want more
regular season games and that's what is
driving this periodic questioning of the
value in the quality of the preseason
nothing more nothing less
yeah well you're right I mean at the end
of the day it's it's the dollars that
are talking and it's two extra games of
you know yes a TV deal you talked about
with the legal gamble izing you know
last hour that okay two more games of
you know 16 games for a week of more
gambling more action more cash in the
pockets of everybody so that's certainly
the end goal they're not fooling anybody
that way now to his points about the
preseason being a little pointless
agreed with them a hundred percent you
know again you know the this is a deep
topic really but the preseason game is
is really more risk than reward at this
point right now and we've seen some of
the successful teams in football the
last few years really play very little
in the preseason you know maybe one
series to series a game with their
starters things like that but I think
ultimately - if you're not gonna have
preseason games because these are one of
the
the few times that guys you really get a
chance to tackle and work on some of the
things maybe you can't work on on
practice on a consistent basis they're
gonna have to the players everybody's
got to find a way to come some
concessions you got to be made about
practice and being able to simulate some
more game-like
instances and practices maybe to take a
wet to take the place of the preseason
and of course not injure Superstars and
meaningless preseason games and do
things like that but I think something
has to be done there to get those useful
full pads physical reps yeah it's a
tough question I mean ultimately you
don't want to be gamba lysing with the
health of your key players I mean really
you just you don't you never want to be
gamba lysing with anything that I say
game I was like I said the right thing
there what we have seen in recent years
and yeah and this makes it harder to
sell a four-game preseason and and look
the cynical side of me is thinking
there's some coordination between the
league office and some of these teams
like let's make the preseason even more
meaningless by not playing the starters
do you really need to play the starters
more and more talk by guys like chargers
coach Anthony Lin about not playing his
starters very much at all in the
preseason Sean McVeigh doesn't play his
starters very much in the preseason they
made it to the Super Bowl last year I
remember saying last year this is gonna
be a good litmus test
yeah whether or not you should rest your
starters in the preseason the Rams were
great last year wire-to-wire and made it
to the Super Bowl
so I there is something to be said for
not playing your starters in the
preseason but the fewer the starters
play the fewer reps they take that the
harder it is to convince people to show
up and buy those tickets and it puts
more pressure on the Union to agree to
reduce the preseason and increase the
regular season and and I know this is
not a bargaining chip for the league
they really want 18 regular season games
they've wanted it for a decade and now
that legalized gambling is spreading and
it's gonna be 30 states I think within
the next couple of years or more yeah
they want games to bet on that people
care about not these meaningless games
that only the degenerate
they want games that count that people
will be betting on in much greater
quantities and much greater people
involved in in putting the money down
whether it's on the outcome of the game
whether it's the prop bets during the
game it's Soldier Field they're gonna
have in Stadium betting that is the
ultimate dream for the NFL to have the
ability people in the stadiums and at
home gambling on the games and you want
more regular-season games look how I
mean with four preseason games yeah you
mentioned the possibility of okay you
know and if it shrinks or whatever you
know more opportunities to evaluate the
team but you know where do you strike
that balance in our coach right now how
much do you expose your starters in a
four-game preseason to injury our guys
like Anthony Lynn and Sean McVeigh doing
it right or should they be using their
guys a little bit more no I think
they're doing it right I felt like last
year in general throughout the preseason
we saw less starters play than ever
before because they're just too worried
about losing some of these key players
for you know of course the the real the
real meat and potatoes which is the
regular season
you know last hour I mentioned a little
bit about you know the rosters and you
know some people go oh well what about
you know some of these guys trying to
earn spots they need preseason games you
know Bologna the 53-man roster I'm just
telling you 48 47 spots out of the 53
spots are already filled before training
camp starts it's just gonna be a two or
three position battles here and there
maybe a diamond in the rough somebody
that just pops during training camp or
they go whoa where the heck did this guy
come from
but really the rosters made up by the
time you go to training camp so it's
really just about the ability to get
your team to get it to the highest level
it possibly can be by week one and you
know we've heard a lot of coaches
complain it's hard right now to get your
team totally ready and where the coaches
want them to be with the current
practice status status so if you're not
gonna play the preseason games and if
you're gonna be one of those teams that
keeps your starter out of preseason
games what do you do guys like McVeigh
Anthony Lin they make practice more
intense they do it that way because then
the players know they got games arrests
altogether to me the big thing to going
forward and
if the NFL wants to make the preseason
still conversational to where they can
make it interesting for fans and
everything - you know again this is New
England who started this but again it's
it's you know wwbd what would Belichick
do okay
Belichick started the prep the Pats
preseason practice scrimmages right Mike
we see that every year the Pats link up
with one or two teams they go somewhere
they have a team come up and visit them
you know that's the best way I see right
now to get quality practice reps for
your football team to get them prepared
first of all it's fresh blood you're
going against right you're not gonna get
your guys every day so that's great your
scout team is not having to run scout
team reps you have the other team over
there now so when your defense comes off
the field now they can actually just
come off the field and watch Tom Brady
in the offense right and not have to run
the Scout team and wear themselves down
into the ground even more over
meaningless reps that do nothing for
them so I think these are some of the
avenues at least that I've thought about
that would make sense and I think that's
maybe the future of preseason football
as we go forward yeah even if there are
fewer games I mean you do need to come
up with a better way to ensure that
teams are ready when the regular season
begins look at the Patriots every year
they go through that struggle early on
where the offensive line play maybe is
where it needs to be they haven't had
the opportunities and this is gonna be a
delicate part of the balance for the NFL
and the NFL Players Association because
the NFL PA is not gonna want to give
back the gains that were made in 2011 by
way of reduced practice time and it's
gonna be hard enough to get them to go
to 18 regular season games 18 regular
season games plus more intense practice
time that's not going to go over very
well either so there's a lot of
different ways this can play out but we
are seeing ad emphasis on the preseason
and yes it's being driven by money but
it's going to be for the coaches to come
up with ways to get these guys ready to
go and it's some level the players need
to be willing and interested in going
along with whatever systems are in place
to ensure that they're ready to go when
the games begin that count
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports